hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
i'm just checking in on you
just checking in on you
seeing how you doing oh
billy freckles
wrapped on the movie
i am done well i got to edit the thing
now but i the principal shooting
everybody is wrapped it's done it's in
the can
as they say in the industry very excited
incredible experience
but um
you know i'm on the road right now i'm
in birmingham alabama
home of the university of alabama
birmingham
we're not in tuscaloosa
down here birmingham went on a nice
little [ __ ]
hike with uh not a hike sort of a city
walk with joe bartnick
went up to the uh what do they got they
got this giant viking at the top of this
hill
beautiful
beautiful view and all of that when we
were up there bartnik was like this
looks like the place where they like do
the still shot when they talk about the
weather
you know 75 degree high a low of 59 so
uh bring that windbreaker
um
so anyways i'm out here i'm doing my
first headlining gig since i can't
remember when
end of january beginning of february and
i was on the plane man the plane
when i was on the way out here
um
and i just
looked at this set list that i have i
have 17 new bits
that either i didn't do on my special
that should be coming out a couple of
months
and that i've written since
you know
i did um
[Music]
i taped my special so
[ __ ] my water i have um
they're about three minutes each i would
say on average that's 51 minutes
so the ways i see it
is i have another 19 minutes that i need
to write and when my special comes out
you will come and see me and i will have
totally different material
um
and that's it but until then to fill in
that extra 19 minutes it'll be 19
minutes of [ __ ] that's gonna be on my
next special
so that's how the game works everybody
right and i'll gradually weed that out
you know what that's the toughest thing
for me on the writing a new hour is
getting the right closer
figuring out which is the one that goes
last
that's the hardest thing other than that
it's just me running my yap which i am
good at doing speaking of running
the boston celtics i'm [ __ ] running
the table lately they playing the
milwaukee bucks tonight
um i've sort of been trying to keep an
eye on them obviously it was a little
busy there but uh dare i say one of the
hottest teams in the nba right now
at 50 and 30 playing the milwaukee bucks
tonight 49 at 30. i'm gonna be doing a
show but i'm gonna try to keep an eye on
that
uh bruins have been playing well i know
they lost to the red wings but they it
looks like they won like
like three four in a row a home and a
home home at home against uh columbus
getting all caught up here
we have this new guy what's his name
hampus lindholm i see he had a lower
body injury but people say he wasn't
limping around posture knocks out
this is good though get all the injuries
out of the way right before the playoffs
everybody comes back a little rested you
watch netflix you stretched your hammies
and then hopefully we go on a little bit
of a run here
um but i got to tell you i am listen to
me i'm [ __ ] i'm talking a mile a
minute here i am so [ __ ] excited
to be doing stand-up man i am so i miss
this [ __ ] like you you cannot [ __ ]
believe
um
it really is it's the greatest job in
entertainment it just is
it just is
you know you have to do an hour it takes
an hour
there's no meetings there's no circling
backs there's no pre-meeting before the
meeting there's no notes
there's no nothing
get on stage talk for an hour you're
done
get out of the venue
it's perfect
it's [ __ ]
perfect so um i have some really big
gigs coming up
um
and i'm just gonna be you know when i
get back to la i'm just gonna be doing
stand-up anywhere i can do stand-up and
just get this [ __ ] thing together
editing the movie during the day
playing with my kids in the late
afternoon and then when i get them to
bed i'm going out
uh
to do stand-up and that is it baby
that's gonna be
my life
over the next uh couple of months here
and uh i can't wait
i can't wait i feel like i'm a thousand
pounds lighter today
no more responsibility
um
at least for a week and then i go into
the editing room but uh yeah got to
thank everybody that worked with that we
just had the coolest [ __ ] set ever
everybody was cool everybody was mellow
everybody had a [ __ ] great time the
last day of the shoot we brought in a
cigar roller a little trick i learned
when i did pete davidson's movie he
brought somebody in and the cigars were
delicious everybody had a good time had
a little root beer
um
yeah man it was [ __ ] awesome so
anyway i got out here
last night
connected through dallas we had this
friggin airplane
where uh
you know you know the captain gets on
and first of all you know
if these [ __ ] planes you get on the
planes they have the intercom on like
full blast and this was one was like
extra full blast in the past i've asked
him to turn it down a little bit
and the stewardess always says yeah
there's nothing we can do
it's like what do you mean there's
nothing we can do
are you honestly telling me that they
installed an intercom
on full [ __ ] blast without a knob on
it is that what you're telling me what
it really is is they're lawyers
just in case somebody's hard of hearing
we have to have it up full blast so
nobody can sue us the guy next to me was
literally blocking his ears
it was so [ __ ] loud
um that's what it's going to take
some ambulance chaser to say they
collapsed my
eardrum so um anyway the guy gets on
just like loud as [ __ ]
[Applause]
she captain speaking right and he's like
uh
we have a mechanical issue it's not the
plane it's one of our mid-cabin
laboratories
i guess it was stinking up the joint and
i don't know what happened but like i
was you know
listening to the people working at lax
talking to the uh the male stewardess
guy there
and
they were just like yeah you know what
do you want us to do about it and the
guy was just like this is how you talk
to us it was really [ __ ]
unprofessional
you know whoever that guy at lax was he
sounded like a guy
who had to go fix a public toilet
so maybe it wasn't unprofessional maybe
it was just normal human behavior of i
don't want to [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
so eventually they got it
they got it done
and uh we had to connect through dallas
and i never sweat that [ __ ] whenever
they're like you know i might miss my
connecting flight it's just like i know
people in dallas
i'll call up jeff sewell
[ __ ] one of my favorite little people
in the business there's peter dinklage
and then there's jeff sewell
and uh
i [ __ ] i would just hang out with him
that's what i was thinking then i'll get
a rental car and i'll drive across this
great nation
i'll go through texas tyler texas homer
earl campbell
childhood home and then i'll [ __ ] go
through
louisiana
through mississippi right in there i
don't give a [ __ ]
me and bartnik would ride they were like
[ __ ] we'll get a [ __ ] rental car
it'll be fine
and because i didn't give a [ __ ] if you
believe in the universe
not only did i make my flight they
changed my gate to being right next door
you know dallas is probably the worst
one i've ever had to connect in
um
i really think that they
installed the train going the wrong way
because every time i get there and i
have to connect my connection say if
there's four terminals
and you know the thing runs
counterclockwise the train
i'm always
one terminal to the right so i have to
go through all of the terminals
to get or you can run like a lunatic
with your bag
i've never really figured out which one
is quicker but um
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] anymore you get
to a certain age you're just too old to
run for a plane and it's just like all
right
either i make it
or i'm gonna find out what local sports
team is playing and i'm going to that
game
tell me what brings you to town i miss
my connecting flight and you came out
here to a [ __ ] tuscaloosa wahoo game
yes i did i don't give a [ __ ]
what division is this 19 well [ __ ] let's
get after it then you meet people next
thing you know you're shooting guns you
go you join a hate group
and the next day you're at hurts you act
like it never happened anymore right now
you get back on your [ __ ] plane
um no i shouldn't say hate group just
because we're down south doesn't mean
that these white people down here hate
anybody else anymore
oh [ __ ] i'm going to talk about that
tonight on stage that's a good way to
get in with these people from alabama
um
by the way somebody was sending me clips
of donald trump and i have to tell you
he is
one of my favorite
accidental stand-up comedians or comedic
actors
of all [ __ ] time
and i cannot take anybody seriously that
voted for that guy i just can't
i just like how many times can you look
the other way with this guy
somebody sent me this thing he was
talking about people throwing bags of
soup
at police office he's like heavy bags of
soup
he's just so full of [ __ ]
that he just has to [ __ ] but
you know they're all full of [ __ ] okay
i'm not saying oh forgetful freddie
there isn't full of [ __ ] but like
there has to be a certain level of
intelligence
you know i mean that that's that's my
[ __ ] thing
with sports fans
with with nationalistic people and then
people who pick a political party where
they just get so into it that they can't
that they get to the point that they
can't call a dumb [ __ ] a dumb [ __ ]
just because they're on your team or
they're wearing the the political
colored tie you like or they're from
your country i mean that's one of the
[ __ ] flaws
of human beings and i've been guilty of
it where you'd rather win than be right
you know and you just be like this guy's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] and then they'll be like
whoa [ __ ] so and so said some dumb
[ __ ]
it's like all right yeah no they're all
dumb they're all dumb just say it with
me
to say they're they're all
joe biden is like that that guy
shouldn't be
thank god he became president we got him
off the road he's not driving anymore
um
anyway
uh let's let's not get into politics but
it's just like i there's nobody in the
world that i love listening
try to convey an idea
as much
as like donald trump should have a
[ __ ] netflix special like when that
guy isn't president he is one of the
funniest human beings i've ever heard in
my life
he's like such a character but then when
he became you know
i don't know like like joe biden would
be [ __ ] hilarious if he wasn't
president
like you start to wonder like it's like
weekended bernie's they just like
wheeled the guy out with [ __ ]
sunglasses on um i think it's a well the
kids call it a deep fake they probably
have somebody else that still has their
marbles together talking for the guy
um
anyway what's going on with russia and
uh
oh my god i'm ready
why can't i ever remember the name of
that country
kiev i can remember the name of the
capitol
oh dude i you know so i need like a
[ __ ]
mental break
is what i need
um
ukraine jesus christ the ukraine
is that he said kayev kiev i don't know
how to say what's going on with that all
of a sudden like they're not reporting
on it i'm hearing that the underdogs are
starting to win some [ __ ]
they're starting to win some uh let me
see like who's winning here could you
give me this he's got to be rooting for
the ukraine
ukraine here we go
uk versus russia
uh
who's
who's winning
because i saw some great [ __ ] where they
were [ __ ]
i don't know i feel like they're only
showing us the highlights ukraine russia
wore casualty so far who's winning who
is winning in the ukraine russian war
the war that has started between russia
why can't they just give you the answer
why can't the west admit that the
ukraine is winning i'm ready to admit
that i want that to happen
america is too accustomed to thinking of
its side
as stymied ineffective or incompetent
is that what we're used to uh when i
visit iraq during the 2007 search i
discovered that the conventional wisdom
in washington usually lagged the view
from the field two to four weeks
something similar applies today analysts
and commentators have grudgingly
declared that the russian invasive
ukraine has been blocked
and that the war is stalemated
look at that shout out to the ukraine
the with the goal line defense
i mean you just you you have to vote for
the underdog that's why i don't get mad
at people when they [ __ ]
root for people that we're fighting
i mean well that's what i would be doing
if i didn't live here
right
you always have to vote the underdog i
think if you vote for the favorite that
just says something about you
right
which is why when i became a college
football fan i didn't you know i didn't
jump on the alabama [ __ ] wagon i went
lsu
i like [ __ ] uh
auburn
georgia
um
tennessee i like
university of kentucky i just can't get
into they're just always gonna be a
basketball school for me
oh speaking of which how about a shout
out to the kansas jayhawks i missed that
game because i was working
um i did i had a break at one point and
i saw they were down by 15 points at the
half
and they just
right out of the locker room they just
came out there
and just they [ __ ] took it to him
[ __ ] carolina couldn't hit a bucket
but i heard carolina came back and then
one of the big men got uh hurt and once
he got hurt that was it
but um
this is something else that i didn't
know
i thought like
you know if you asked me like how many
titles like north carolina had i think
they had like
10 or 12 or whatever i didn't realize i
wasn't really thinking that i knew ucla
had the most but i thought they had more
than 11
but
when you think about it when you have a
one in 64 chance
that there's 64 teams making the
playoffs
playoffs
it's one of the harder championships to
win
as far as odds go
so it's ucla has 11.
kentucky has eight i think
it's in kentucky
then unc has six duke has five
like they're like everybody's in single
digits except ucla i found that uh
pretty amazing
um
as amazing as i want to see what happens
to the duke program
now that coach k is gone
you know this is such a critical [ __ ]
time where the next guy has to win
you got to keep it going
even though they won for 40 straight
[ __ ] years 42 straight years
with coach k
it's like
how university of north carolina it was
critical that when dean smith stepped
down that they continued to win
and i want to say in the early 90s that
montrose team was he coaching that one i
wanted to say by then that was already
his son or something like that but they
were able to keep it going because
watching like what happened with the
university of michigan football
where
you go from winning and being a
destination school it only takes like
five six years of losing
and then kids don't view the school
as
like you know
a winning program
like seven eight years you gotta figure
an incoming freshman you've been losing
since he was 10 years old
you know i don't think he's really
paying attention to college history but
he's been watching the last eight years
he was as he was moving up the ranks in
football and all he does is see you lose
to ohio state every [ __ ] year
um
like that was why it was so huge today
this past year when michigan finally
beat ohio state
you got it at some point you got to get
like that big victory or what you do is
what oregon did you never win [ __ ]
but you come out with those disco ball
[ __ ] helmets and there's enough good
players out there like man i want to
wear that uniform
um which is one of the most interesting
ways i've ever seen a program built
is that they
they
came out with these space-age buck roger
[ __ ] uniforms and it literally turned
the program a while around for a little
while i think they kind of settled back
down though
am i crazy
i have no idea i'll tell you what i got
right now crazy free time
over the next week whoa
um
yeah you know what i did before i got on
my flight you know what the [ __ ] i did
well of course i played with my kids and
i took my
took him to school and all of that [ __ ]
but after that
after that i actually went and i played
drums for like a second
like five minutes i just ten minutes or
whatever whatever time i had
um i have gotten a bad habit
as a parent where i bribed my son with
cookies
you know because he's like super strong
and really strong-willed
and like if you start if you're carrying
him like okay we're going inside you go
to pick him up he just like grabs two
handfuls
of your t-shirt any and he started no
he says pointing the other way
so the other day there was some people
over and they were uh
you know trimming the trees
let me get fires out here you got to
make sure you don't have all this [ __ ]
touching your house right so the trim in
the trees
and my son was just fascinated by it
he was going hi hi saying hello to
everybody because he's a little
sweetheart and uh every time i would go
to go inside he would just grab me like
i owed him money just two hands full of
t-shirt
and he and he would start flipping out
and then finally
i was like oh you want to keep watching
him he's like yeah
and i'm like all right
and then finals like dude we have to go
inside because i got to go to the
airport and everything he starts you
know
flipping out again and finally i just go
i go you want a cookie
and then he just looks at the workers in
the tree and he waves he goes
bye-bye
[Music]
we started walking in the house i go
cookie he goes cookie
so i gave him half a
girl scout cookie
it's kind of funny you know what i've
i'm finding like
you know the good cop bad cop thing
in uh my relationship
with my lovely wife is uh sorry i'm
yawning here still [ __ ] wiped out um
i'm finding is uh
she's more of a
a disciplinarian which is good
like she calls him out
on their [ __ ]
and i'm just too much of a softie so
what i really have to do but i'm smart
enough that i know i cannot undermine
you get you got to be a unified front
as a couple with your kids or else
they'll just start you know
going around they'll just they'll just
go to the person that's going to say yes
in that situation but i have to admit
it's like really
it's really hard for
me because i have to admit like when
when a kid has a meltdown i just think
it's
it's [ __ ] funny to me
it's funny or i just go what are we
doing here what are we doing here but
it's like funny to me but like
my wife is so good at seeing what that
behavior is gonna lead to
i think i i have too much of like
you know i got yelled at as a kid i
didn't like that so i'm gonna be you
know i'm gonna take a different approach
and i think my kids both of them already
know that i'm i'm the softie
that they can kind of get over on so i
got to kind of like you know
i got to come more my wife's way because
you know
she knows all the tricks
she goes no what she does is when she
doesn't like her dinner she just says
she's full and her stomach hurts
and then we throw it out and then like
an hour later she says she's hungry and
then asks for what she really wants i
mean that sounds like a really simple
caper right but she was getting me on it
all the time
and i was like oh i don't want you to go
to bed hungry what do you want you want
you want some cereal
my wife is looking at me like
this is why she's not eating her
vegetables she's doing this and then i'm
like oh yeah you're right like i'm a
more i really am a [ __ ] [ __ ] when it
comes to that [ __ ] so
um and i'll tell you one of my favorite
things
in the world is watching my wife be a
mother
because she is amazing at it she has
everything is like perfectly balanced
she's silly she's fun
she's affectionate
and but then she knows when to drop the
hammer like all right that's enough
that's enough that's enough and i know
what you're doing
you know
i feel like i'm sergeant schultz
on [ __ ]
what was it at mchale's navy on uh not
kelly's heroes
the [ __ ] was that called
jesus christ
i see nothing
hogan's heroes there we go
um all right butcher box everybody look
who it is
oh butcher box you know meal prepping is
difficult butcher box makes it easy
butcher box is a subscription service
that takes the guesswork out of finding
high quality meat butcher box sources
their meat from partners with the
highest standards for quality no more
searching the grocery store
sorry for 100 grass-fed beef free-range
organic chicken and wild caught alaskans
wild-caught seafood you don't know what
they're gonna do and more
their sourcing decisions are made
holistically keeping the farmer
the planet the animal and your family in
mind each box contains between 8 to 14
pounds of meat depending on the box you
choose that's enough for 24 individual
meals packed fresh and shipped frozen
for your convenience so you can save
time on your next trip to the grocery
store customize your own box or go with
one of theirs either way you get exactly
what you want this is your chance to
never
have to shop for ground beef again
that's right butcher box is giving new
members free ground brief for life plus
get a 10 off coupon sign up at
butcherbox.com get two pounds of ground
beef free in every order for the life of
your membership plus a 10 off coupon log
on to butcherbox.com
claim the deal
um
all right
so there you have it so i'm in uh
birmingham tonight i'm in macon georgia
tomorrow and then i'm going to the
masters and i'm going to put on the tv
right now because i know tiger woods
probably about halfway through his round
hoping he's making the cut
and i'll get to see that legend one more
time
and with that
please listen to a little bit of
anything better clip
and after that we'll have a little bit
of music interlude unless we don't have
anything better clip i can't remember
which
um and then you'll get a bonus half hour
of thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcasts
um after all right that's it have a
great weekend you [ __ ]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
april [ __ ] 7th
what's going on how are you i apologize
for the uh
the bad sound on the recording
um
i am right now i am overseas i am in gay
patty
i don't mean that in a homophobic way
um that's just what they call it i think
gay still means happy over here
it used to mean happy in uh united
states of america before gay people
stole that word
you know and then started telling people
how they can use it
how they can't use it
it doesn't make any sense to me you
don't own a word
anyways um
mean how come stupid you know how come
dope
and stupid could actually mean something
good
right
but you j can't mean that's lame
i guess because it's it's it's
coming from gay meaning uh
same-sex
i don't know i've never understood it
i can say like you know that that
[ __ ] band is big gay
meaning lame
and still not care if gay people
get married
like why why does everybody have to be a
[ __ ] parent right now and just say
what you can say and what you can't say
it doesn't make a difference what the
[ __ ] you say it's what's in your [ __ ]
heart right
all you're doing is you're just giving a
road map
for psychos on how to get through the
minefield without showing their hand
you know
and that's how you end up with another
hitler i'm joking maybe a mussolini
though
i'm sorry i'm gonna try not to move the
computer here the reason why i'm
recording this way is because uh
i finally figured it out after two times
being over here or overseas i think i
was in australia one time and i've blown
out my [ __ ] mixer
mixer
uh what i figured out over here for you
you people
my countrymen
in the states uh do not plug anything
with two only two prongs
into a [ __ ] wall over here my
experience is it it
either blows out the plug
that's the best case scenario or just
completely
damages and uh [ __ ] over
whatever device you were trying to put
in i've lost two mixers
i tried to plug my iphone in
and i'm saying this is with an adapter
too
i didn't just stick it in a wall i
actually used an adapter and uh
i did that with my uh
my iphone charger for the 4s and thing
[ __ ] blew up
i should have known because i was
charging it earlier and it was working
fine and when i pulled it out of the
wall it was really hot
now i don't understand electricity to me
it's still magic
and you somehow trapped lightning and
put it in the wall
[Music]
that's what electricity is to me it's
lightning
you know
because my only education about it was
when old fatso
with his male pattern baldness and his
[ __ ] glasses flew the kite down there
in philly
you know
and he went out there and he was all
hammered
because uh he was making excuses for his
alcoholism
isn't that what he did he said yeah beer
is uh
proof that god loves us
yeah what a filthy old man he must have
been
coming down the street with his giant
mug i bet ben franklin was the first one
to have like a personalized mug
at a bar or something
like the first norm from cheers as he
comes stumbling in
this stupid slurring witty systems
witty scissors witticisms however the
[ __ ] you say it i don't know um anyways
so yeah i'm over here on vacation
finally took a vacation i've always
wanted to come here and why the [ __ ] not
right
what else am i gonna do
huh
go to [ __ ] santa fe
um no i've always wanted to come here
and it has been absolutely incredible
and i did not brush up on my french
whatsoever
i mean
there wasn't really anything to brush up
on i like how i just said that as if i
was
at one point semi-fluent in the language
i wasn't i will tell you that i took it
from sixth grade
to uh twelfth grade and i never
progressed past french one
and um
actually i did i got the french 2a and i
did so poorly my dad suggested why don't
you go back to french one and start over
again and get the basics
and i was like all right that sounds
like a good idea and in theory it was a
good idea because i still had my junior
and senior years to get through french
too and have my two years of a language
you know
because that was a big thing when i went
to cup when i went to high school you
have to have two years of a language if
you don't have two years of a language
you're not going to be able to get into
any college worth anything
in the united states of america of
course turned out to be complete
horseshit
all you have to do if you [ __ ] up in
high school is go to any college that
you want to go to and just say listen
can i just start taking courses to prove
that i can exist at this academic level
and in the head is they just think yeah
we'll take your money stupid we'll take
it go ahead pay for a couple of classes
flunk out we got your money you're dumb
[ __ ] but if you actually hang in there
eventually they have to accept you
that's the other way to get into a big
school
you know
me personally i think what you should
really do if you want to save some
[ __ ] money and you weren't born the
daddy wore bucks
i don't know if that's the right
reference i've never seen
annie
i thought the whole thing was offensive
i didn't like how annie looked exactly
how i looked when i was a child in the
70s and that they then made it a woman
i took it as a personal attack but
that's a whole other [ __ ] story
anyways if you weren't born into a rich
family what you really want to do
is
go to a uh
go to a community college for your first
two years
what's that like 700 bucks a year
or a semester whatever the [ __ ] it is
you knock that out this half your
[ __ ] college education bing bang boom
you having to eat you haven't had to pay
[ __ ] and you get then then you transfer
to a bigger school
in the better school and then you only
have to pay two years and you know at
the end of it you've got the same degree
hanging on the [ __ ] walls the other
jerk off
um but anyways
anyways mental
back to being here in france uh so what
i've been doing is
i've been going on to this duolingo
website and i gotta tell you it's been
phenomenal and i've been over here in
paris
having conversations you know
basic conversations
in french
with these parisians who i told were
unbelievably rude
and to just speak english to them
because they hate when you try and speak
french
and they'll roll their eyes
and you'll try to talk to them in
english and they'll either stomp away or
they'll just speak to you in english
condescending condescending
condescending all of that [ __ ]
i have to tell you my experience um
nothing could be further from the truth
these people have been ridiculously
polite
they're really [ __ ] nice
and if you're making an effort
to speak their language they're actually
cool with it if you just sit there and
you're like uh blah blah blah blah
wherever you go do i say that right and
they'll laugh and they'll they'll just
kind of
help you along with it that's what i
find i found a couple of impatient
people but you know what the [ __ ]
um
i don't know i think it kind of goes
back to that that same thing like with
new yorkers i always heard new yorkers
were rude and pushy
and when i moved there i didn't find
that i found them to be really friendly
so uh either
people are making up [ __ ] or i'm [ __ ]
up one or the other it's probably a
little bit of both
but i've been here for about five days
and uh i can't say enough about the
people man i i think they're great and
um
the lovely mia
she's unbelievable when it comes to
speaking other languages she just like
i swear to god i was telling her the
other day like she could be like a spy
because she'll sit there and she'll
start speaking in french and her french
is so good that they just roll with it
here
and then they start saying [ __ ] and i
know mia doesn't know what they're
talking about
but she doesn't betray that on her face
she just sits in the pocket and she
watches their
body language and their mannerisms
and she picks up on what they're saying
and then she responds to it with the
french that she knows
or if she doesn't she gives him a smile
and then asks him in english is that
what you're talking about and they
absolutely
[ __ ]
love her
me on the other hand i've been able to
get to uh
i had one cab ride that was entirely in
french
um
which like made my whole [ __ ] trip
i figure this is how you learn the
language if you ever lived over here uh
how to get you know have a cab ride and
ordering food seems to be the way to go
the first time so i've been trying to
learn all these different
you know words for food and that type of
[ __ ] over here but it's been uh
it's been tremendous i've always wanted
to come here and i gotta tell you
um the limited amount of places that
i've been to over here
or around the world i should say uh this
is the
visually the most unbelievable city i've
ever been to
i mean uh
these sons of [ __ ] knew what they
were doing when they were laying this
thing out it's incredible
absolutely incredible like
i've been to like
i think three parks here
or two
two giant parks here that could [ __ ]
with central park
well they're not as big as central park
they have another one that's as big as
central park i haven't been to that one
yet you know what's funny as i looked it
up on the internet and i guess at night
that's where the hookers are
[Laughter]
and you know what i gotta tell you their
hookers are pretty [ __ ] gorgeous
that's another thing too best looking
[ __ ] women as far as a country
i've ever gone to
and that includes
i mean this just might be personal taste
this includes sweden and norway where
the women were drop dead gorgeous
and uh iceland too like
the french women are [ __ ]
unbelievable plus they're speaking
french you
know who the hell doesn't like a
gorgeous woman speaking french you know
i don't maybe you don't this is just all
my own
personal opinions here but um
anyways these other two parks that
that i've gone to um
the way that they do it it's like you
walk into the park
and it's sort of you're covered like
just
trees all around you
and that's beautiful enough with park
benches and all that
um
and then you basically walk
i don't know how far i don't know how
many meters how many yachts
but you get all the way in
um whatever about four or five football
fields and once you get in all of a
sudden it just
comes to this
like giant open area and then you have
these 365 degree views
of like museums
old governmental buildings
or like the eiffel tower all of a sudden
will just be
there like a like a goddamn mountain in
the distance it's
um
literally breathtaking you know and i
know you guys can attract me for saying
that but i swear to god it's uh
it's i can't say enough about it and um
if i was ever gonna live
i think somewhere else
i mean first of all i always wanted to
learn to speak another language and also
because this place is incredible
and i've only seen
a little bit of it and i'll tell you
about it after uh after these messages
here i got to do a little bit of
advertising here i apologize for the
click and sound if this is like extra
loud but like i said
my [ __ ] mixer only has uh
only has the two prongs and i'm not
sticking that in the wall because you
know i buy like 90 mixers so that's
another thing too about your devices
over here if you got something that cost
you about a hundred bucks
it's some sort of elect piece of
electronics do not plug it into the
[ __ ] wall with or without any well
without an adapter it's probably gonna
blow up
um
as opposed to just getting shorted out
the other way okay here we go
stamp.com everybody
um the post office is always crowded now
it'll be even more crowded with people
mailing in their taxes but you still
need to get out envelopes and packages
for your business what do you do use
stamps.com instead stamps.com brings all
the services for the post office right
to your desk it's so convenient and easy
to use you can buy and print official us
postage for any letter any package using
your computer and printer then just hand
it to your mailman stance.com even send
you a free digital scale that
automatically calculates uh the extra
postage you need and the scale is scale
is yours to keep you'll never have to go
to the post office again i use
stamps.com to send out all my dvds my
posters
uh my my re-elect billboard buttons
whatever thing i'm selling
you know whatever i'm pouring out at the
end of my shows uh right now you can use
my last name burp b-u-r-r for this
special offer no risk trial plus a free
110 dollar bonus offer that includes a
digital scale and up to 55 dollars in
free postage don't wait go to stamps.com
before you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in bur bur
next what do we got here oh legalzoom
everyone
modern technology is great smartphones
ipads and other gadgets make it easy to
do so many things
but why is it that our lives seem busier
at the same time well i got theories on
that but i don't have time to totally
tell you about them uh but when it comes
to getting to the legal help you need
legalzoom provides a great solution that
works with your busy schedule let's face
it the legal system is complicated um
there are better things you can do with
your time thankfully legalzoom is there
for you so if you're thinking about
starting a business forming an llc or
getting a trademark will or living trust
legalzoom gets the job done right you'll
get the personal attention you need to
help you take care of all the details
legalzooms been helping families and
small business owners for over 14 years
and they received an a plus
from the better business bureau
and a plus people call or visit
legalzoom today for an extra discount
enter bur in the referral box at
checkout that's legalzoom.com discount
code burr legalzoom provides legal help
to independent attorneys and self-help
services but it is not a law firm go to
legalzoom.com enter discount code burr
um and what do we got here one more
dollar shave club everyone nothing feels
better than that first shave with a
fresh blade right it's smooth it's close
and the blade is as sharp as ever
it feels fantastic but thanks to the big
shapes
what but thanks to the big shaves
company's ridiculous prices you can't
afford to use a fresh blade every week
can you so you drag that dull ass blade
across your face face for two weeks
three weeks ten weeks however long
depending on your cash situation why
would you do that to yourself maybe
because the only thing more painful than
shaving with an old blade is shelling
out 30 bucks for a pack of new ones
um if you want to enjoy a fresh blade
every week but you don't want to take
out another mortgage on your house you
gotta join dollarshave.com for just a
couple of bucks bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com ships the highest
quality blade you can get
um i use these things when i'm out here
on the road they're absolutely
phenomenal everything they're saying
about them is true and you know what
it's only six bucks for the best quality
blades you can get so every week i can
pop in a fresh blade and treat myself to
an amazing shave i try i'm finally
treating my face like my own face you
know it's incredible uh join
dollarshaveclub.com get amazing quality
braid blades in the mail every couple
for a couple of bucks and treat yourself
to a brand new blade every single week
hundreds of thousands of guys have
upgraded their shaving with
dollarshaveclub.com
i'm one of them and i'm loving it now
it's your turn shave time shave money
dollarshaveclub.com
that's dollarshaveclub.com
all right back to the podcast here
um oh and i also forgot to mention uh
i did have a couple of things that i i
wanted to bring up before i get going
too far uh the all-in comedy tour
kicked off at um
jesus christ now where the [ __ ] is it
is it right here
yeah there we go the all things comedy
tour kicked off down at largo
last monday hosted by yours truly
all right
kicking uh kicking all my buddies out of
the nest here so they can go out on the
road
and uh headline themselves headline
their own tours the all in comedy tour
starring uh rose bold tailgate legends
joe bartnick
jason lawhead
and uh
my good friend paul verzi
i actually got some great feedback
on the tour they did their first date
alone down in san diego
and here's a review here's an email i
got
uh
dear william i might be your biggest
west coast fan i saw you on new year's
eve and just checked out the all in show
in san diego last week wow those guys
were hilarious joe jason and andrew
andrew themeless who helps me on the
podcast here actually came down for the
show uh were just as awesome as they
were at the wilton joe bartnick is an
animal
there's never been a true thing said he
says if that's the way he does comedy i
hate to see him drunk actually you'd
love to see him drunk uh lawhead is a
spitfire he did a great impersonation of
the guy from bar rescue
by request of the other guys on the show
oh by the way we got a video of that we
got some video of that uh jason lawhead
does a [ __ ] hilarious
impression of the bar rescue guy we're
gonna have that up here on the podcast
page
um and he said i was quoting andrew
females to my co-workers the next day
and now on diversity holy [ __ ] paul
versus hilarious he's the only one of
your four horsemen i've never seen
perform you don't keep any slouches
around i highly recommend your podcast
listeners check out their other shows
i'd be the water boy on this tour too i
was hoping you were actually a guy in
the audience in disguise and you were
going to stand up and rip off your fake
mustache and jump up on stage thanks for
the podcast and go [ __ ] yourself uh
there's actually a chance
um
that i might pop in on a uh a show or
possibly two on this tour you never know
but just let you know tonight they're at
helium comedy club
great comedy club in portland oregon um
tomorrow tuesday they're at the punch
line in san francisco actually tuesday
and wednesday that the punch line in san
francisco and thursday they're at the
punch line in sacramento all very all
great clubs it's an amazing show they're
all my buddies i'd love if you had time
to go out and support these guys the
show starts at 8pm
um see them all in the same bill you're
going to get to be able to tell your
friends that someday
and uh oh and also um tom segura
one of my favorite um i call them new
comedians because i'm an old guy and um
he's also one of the members here in the
uh all things comedy network
he has a new comedy special out his
first hour special called completely
normal it's available if you want to
purchase it on itunes if you just want
to check it out and uh
get them some views on netflix you can
obviously check it out on netflix all
right i've done one in my mouth here
so back to the
back to the tour here um
i just realized i'm wearing headphones
and i can't even hear myself
not the tour back to the uh the trip up
here
in france um
so yeah we got here on uh
wednesday of last week and uh i got to
admit
i haven't seen i haven't really done any
touristy [ __ ]
uh i just kind of been sitting in cafes
watching people going by
you know eating some great food and um
renting a bicycle
riding around like a twinkle toes having
a good time doing that
uh walked along the river's end if you
ever get a chance to do that um you're
gonna see these stairs that go down
where you can get really close to the
river
do not i repeat do not do that
um i think that's where everyone in
paris when they can't make it to the
bathroom takes a piss
because
it literally smells like the ford
authority down there if you stay up
a pie along the road it's incredible
and um
i don't know we've just been having a
great time here i'm trying to get mia to
come down here to the podcast she's
still sleeping she's got a little bit of
jet lag
uh
i don't know you know what i'll hit
pause here in a few minutes and i'll
actually
go into the other room and see if i can
get her i apologize if this is too quiet
we're actually staying in a very quiet
building here we um
we rented an apartment here
which uh
it's definitely more expensive but it's
kind of
you save money by basically you know
because then you have a kitchen
so what you do is you just go down the
road
you know you walk outside
and you [ __ ]
maybe you learn some french words on
food you go in you go try to have a uh
try to go buy your groceries all
speaking only french
i was almost able to do it i fooled it i
can always fool them for the first
couple of words and they kind of figure
it out and they slowly start speaking
english but i kind of just stick with
the french like i'm trying to learn it
at that point i just say i'll say the
english word and then try to say the
french word and then just say is that
how you say it and then they usually
correct me or whatever but uh whatever
then you can just bring it back load up
your fridge
and i can save a ton of cash that way
um i don't know it's just been amazing
it's been amazing uh
i haven't been able to get up early
enough to get a fresh baguette
and uh i will i can tell you that that's
something else that i learned here
is nothing
nothing goes faster than a [ __ ]
baguette in the morning
these get these people like that's one
of the true stereotypes
like when you see them walking down the
street or riding a bicycle with the
baguette these [ __ ] people
are into those goddamn things and they
try to be the first person in line
i mean dude they they're gone
they're [ __ ] gone by like by the time
i get up at like 11 30
it's probably the earliest i've been
getting up around 10 o'clock 11 30 or
whatever they're just [ __ ] gone
there's like two or three left
and um
i don't know so uh i already forget the
name of bakery how you say bakery out
here
ah [ __ ] i don't know
but uh
neil will know i keep thinking i learned
words like the shen and she go no she in
it's like you know what liv
[ __ ] you you know just it's kind of
annoying because you know what i
actually kind of got pissed a couple
times when she did that to me because i
felt like i was back in french class
it's like am i ever going to get this
[ __ ] down
um so anyways as i mentioned uh we
haven't seen
the only touristy things that i i've
seen is i've just stood and looked at
them like the notre dame
i basically uh
one day this is a great city to get lost
into because you just use the river as
your guide
um
i just kind of go in about five ten
twenty blocks
although you can get lost because the
river sort of want river sand kind of
winds down the middle of it but it's
it's been a pretty good way to try to
figure out where the hell you're at
um
but like i walked by it and notes it
down
and
it was beautiful and everything but i'm
not a big religious guy and then i saw
the line of people outside of it and i
just laughed like why the [ __ ]
i understand if you have kids and you're
trying to teach them something but if
you're a [ __ ] adult and you're on
vacation there's no reason to ever stand
in line you're on vacation why would you
do that to yourself
you know
like we were sitting there i was trying
to find the art did try off
and i i i couldn't figure out where the
[ __ ] thing was and one of these great
moments just wandering around paris and
i saw this beautiful park and i was just
like neil let's go in there she's
walking there she's like alright so we
start walking in
and i started to take in the view and i
turned around and i looked over my
shoulder
and i was looking right up these charms
delivery however the [ __ ] you say it
and
basically at the end of that street is
the arc the triumph all the way in the
back and i literally got goosebumps
because all i've ever seen
of that monument
is two video footage
one when hitler uh when the germans
had defeated france and they were
driving up that [ __ ] street
and then two when uh
england and the americans came in and we
uh
helped france get the germans out of
their [ __ ] country
uh
all of them you know all the french
women and everybody going [ __ ] crazy
it really gave me chills and i kept
saying that to me i know i was freaking
around there's no way to say hitler
drove up this street in an excited way
without freaking out the person that
you're with
[Laughter]
and i had to
you know i'm a i like that
history [ __ ] you know what i mean it's
like one of the most evil guys ever who
was well on his way
to taking over the world and possibly
you know the height of him taking over
the
his quest
was him driving up that famous street
and uh
i don't know i somebody got fun i was on
the road in um
in canada
somebody got me a uh gave me this book
uh the guns of august
and it's about world war one and it's
phenomenal
and uh
i knew that france had lost to germany
in world war one and world war ii
initially
both wars but i didn't realize that
in like 1870 they had had another war
and germany won that one ah why didn't i
bring the book down here i'll read the
quote next week
and basically
france lost
france straight up lost that war
it wasn't like world war one world war
ii where they got occupied then
eventually got him out of there
at least i think that's what happened in
world war one because i i don't know
much about that war but
in 1870 they [ __ ] lost and aside from
having to give up some land
one of the things
part of this the treaty and the end is
they had to let the germans drive up
that street the champs-elysees right
and not one french person showed up
it was just one of the darkest days in
their history
i mean talk about absolute [ __ ]
humiliation right
so these sons of [ __ ] drive drove up
the street and uh
and then they had to pay like like some
ridiculous amount of francs
as a punishment i want to say 5 billion
but there's no way anybody could afford
that back in [ __ ] 1870. it was
supposed to take an entire generation
for them to pay it back to the germans
which would obviously keep france weak
and
these [ __ ] so wanted these guys
off their back they paid it off in three
years
i'm gonna go out on the limb and say
that nobody ate a baguette for [ __ ]
three years here in france and they got
the germans off their backs
and uh so once they did
there was this expression over here i
guess according to the book anyways
where
basically that moment in their history
when the germans drove up
champs-elysees which i'm sure i'm saying
it wrong
uh it was basically said
that it was
something like to never be spoken of
but always thought about
basically never forget but don't bring
it up
that's how how much it hurt them for
that to happen
and it was referred to uh what was it
referred to
i can't remember i can't remember except
i'm the worst
um
basically i didn't realize that that
happened so the fact that [ __ ] hitler
did it again
i don't know if it happened again in
world war one i have no [ __ ] idea
um
i don't know [ __ ] about world war one
but it happened again at world war ii so
it actually happened again
and uh
as far as i've gotten into that book the
guns of august
basically the [ __ ] reason why
germany started
the first one
kind of england and france and everybody
else they were being [ __ ] to the
germans
they just wanted to be acknowledged they
just wanted to be included so i guess
whenever these diplomats would go around
europe
and they would visit everybody always
went to paris everybody went to [ __ ]
paris because paris is the [ __ ]
all right and people would go to london
i don't know whether maybe they'd go to
[ __ ] rome but no one ever went to
berlin
and i guess they started getting this
inferiority complex plus there was a
couple of treaties going on
where just logistically german felt that
they were gonna have to fight a war on
two fronts
and they were gonna get [ __ ] so unless
they
made a move first
they were gonna be in trouble
and uh you know france and england were
playing a good you know the great game
of what we're not going to invade you
we're not going to try to you know
[ __ ]
take over your [ __ ] why would we do that
with france and england we don't have a
record of doing that around the [ __ ]
world for centuries
they kind of had an argument
i'm not i'm talking about world war one
here i'm not talking about the [ __ ]
maniac there in world war two i'm just
saying i actually kind of understood
like oh so that's kind of that that was
their logic
not saying it was the right move but it
was very interesting
so anyways uh this is basically what
i've been doing here and now today i'm
trying to knock the podcast out
uh early
because like i said we haven't done
anything touristy we walked it we walked
up
uh
the champions that street
for uh
to go see the octi trail
and uh it was funny the first it was a
breathtaking streak but the closer you
got to the monument the more i felt like
i was in times square
you know there's like a forever 21
and [ __ ] like that very disappointing
that there was that although i did use a
public back bathroom that cost me two
euros that was the cleanest thing i had
ever been to
um but i didn't realize that you know
you can actually go to the top of that
monument i had no idea and i also still
have no idea how you actually get to the
monument because it's in the middle of a
[ __ ] rotary and there are subway
stairs on the other side and we went
down into the subway and followed the
sign and all it did was spit us out on
the same side i couldn't figure it out
and at the end of the day i have to
stand in a [ __ ] line
to stand up on something where i can
probably get a taller view a higher view
at a [ __ ]
restaurant at the top of a hotel where
there's no line
and i can actually look at the monument
rather than stand on the monument look
at a [ __ ] hotel it doesn't make any
sense if you want to stand behind fat
[ __ ] and jean shorts then go to a
monument and try to go to the top of it
i can tell you that anyways
so then finally me and the uh we're like
three four days there said hey do you
want to look at the eiffel tower now
and she's like yeah
we're both exhausted because that's a
long [ __ ] walk
um oh and by the way the way they have
this their city laid out there's like le
louvre
the their famous museum where the mona
lisa is
which uh i've yet to go see
i'm gonna do that today
all right which i don't like the whole
setup of it
how you have you have to go in you got
to go in to see her because you know
because that [ __ ] ain't coming outside
no you got to uh you got to go and see
the [ __ ] thing i already know i heard
it's really small
and uh
you know she's got that ryan gosling
smile
i'm gonna go do it just to [ __ ] do it
but um every day you walk by that
there's just busloads
of [ __ ] kids getting dragged there by
their french teachers from around the
[ __ ] world
and you know i know that's why i'm going
there on a monday
i figure the weekends are going to be
worse so i'm going to go there and
mia's just like me
when it comes to museums
she likes them for a finite period
museums just make me feel dumb i'm gonna
be honest with you
i go in there and i try
patrice o'neill you said this great bit
about
it was some disaster
like giant disaster that happened and
they were showing all the sad people and
he was talking about how he sat there
and he tried so hard to give a [ __ ]
um which i'm butchering at his delivery
of it of course was perfect
but um
that's how i feel when i'm when i go
into a uh
a museum
the ex
the patrice o'neill bit where i'm trying
so hard
to give a [ __ ]
i i just don't care about old stuff i
respect it i would rather hear a
scientist
i'd rather watch a scientist on
television tell me why what i'm looking
at is so [ __ ] important rather than
going up there and have to read the
index card
it's not even an index card it's like a
[ __ ] notebook paper
size thing
of all this [ __ ] that's just there's too
much [ __ ] to know
then i go in there i'm gonna look at the
knickknacks of all the [ __ ] or the
black
of of the [ __ ]
it's just it's too much all right
i like going to car museums
stuff like that you know
i can i can deal with that so i'm not
saying museums are bad i'm just saying
that um i am not
refined enough
as a human being to actually appreciate
what's going to be in that thing we'll
see i'll talk i'll talk to you about it
next week but um
so anyways we had gone to uh
um
the arctic triumph
and then uh
i finally got all right you want to go
see the eiffel tower i mean we saw it we
saw basically a third of it all the way
to about a half of it from those parks
the amazing views
so
we're both tired from walking up the
street so we got one of those little
bike rickshaw [ __ ] things it was the
greatest so we got jumped in that thing
we're going on the rotary around the
[ __ ] ark
and uh
then we're just riding along riding
along right along and then once again
because the front the french know how to
make a city you go around this
roundabout and then all of a sudden
there's this there's all these buildings
and then there's just this giant gap
and literally i was looking down because
i was like videoing as we were riding
and i just heard nia gasp
and i looked up in there and there was
like like a [ __ ] tyrannosaurus rex
like a giant had just taken up you know
taking a step right toward you
it was unbelievable the greatest tourist
attraction i've ever [ __ ] seen
and i never i didn't even go up and we
never went up in it we just stood there
and looked at it
um
essentially from across the river but
it's it's right on the river
and it's so goddamn big
it was it was incredible and then we
just went across the way and we sat in a
cafe
and just
uh just looked at it
and what's great about the cafes here in
france is they
i've never been to anything like it all
the chairs
are faced out of the street
raw off needy
i think she just came in
all the chairs are just faced out at the
street because you you just you don't
want to miss anything that's going by
all these [ __ ]
beautiful women
all dressed unbelievably
um and then you got the eiffel tower in
the background and we got there
just before dusk and it does they turn
the lights on
oh there she is
bonjour
bonjour
uh come on in
come on in i i was smart enough this
time to not plug my mixer in
right before i stuck it in the wall with
the adapter i saw i saw the two prong
things i'm like wait this is what
happened to me
the last time yeah with my 99 [ __ ]
mixer
well come on over here uh near the uh
the microphone
that means okay everybody i told you
she's good at it
um
so anyways i was just telling them
what are you talking about you just
cleared you oh sorry see that big blip
there you just clear it right near the
microphone oh jim excuse me um
so i was just telling them about taking
that rickshaw bike
over to the uh the eiffel tower and just
how they have the city laid out where
you don't see it you don't see it you
don't see it and then it's just boom
between two buildings and how he was
sitting in that cafe
uh
yeah
that was amazing
at drinking wine and i'm smoking my
little pretentious
cigar cigarette thing
um that's another thing too like
everybody [ __ ] smokes over here it's
hilarious oh it's great there's no
there's no surge in general here
whatsoever but uh
i was mentioning that we're gonna go see
uh the mona lisa today and i'm not a big
museum person and i've i've kind of been
speaking for you on a scale of one to
ten
your feelings about museums
um
you know what i would say i'm at a seven
you guys but i'm not a full-on i'm not a
full-on 10 because
i don't i'm not the kind of person
that's like
wants to spend an entire day in a museum
i want to go in see the [ __ ] that i want
to see and then get out because it's
exhausting
but there are certain things i love i do
love museums but i just don't want to go
there and like like when we're in new
york and i go to the moma i just want to
go in
see some things and leave i don't want
to spend the day at the moment some
people do that and they love it i can't
i can't do that i literally get sick to
my stomach when i hear you say go to the
moma
what do you mean i it's just like i feel
like i'm back in school
and it's the class i hate and i have to
sit there until the bell rings
do you know when i was a single man in
new york
the amount of time people go oh take it
to the museum take it to a museum and it
would always be the worst [ __ ] date
and it was and i would do it because
people say that you know that's where
you take these new york ladies so right
and i would take them there like i was
culture i'm not cultured and i would go
there and i would be bored shitless
and then they would feel it like i'm
telling like 20 minutes 15 20 minutes in
depending on how good looking she was
but the thing 15 20 minutes in i would
be i would just be bored shitless
for a place to buy a hot dog but the
thing is there's certain
there'll be certain exhibits at museums
that you would like remember when we
went to the car museum i said
i like the car museum you like that i
like uh i like there was like a stand-up
comedy
exhibit yeah that's not a museum that's
just cool [ __ ] or like a bunch of cool
uh photographs i could get into right
but the uh
the the artifacts like when we went to
we went to the the [ __ ] thing there
uh the guy who flew on the ceiling that
[ __ ] was 15 chapel you were like
like walking through there like you were
walking through an airport trying to get
to your gate
you were like walking so fast
barely looking at anything you were just
like i'm just walking through this
because i have one because it's the
sistine chapel it was one vest
one vestment after another this priest
was beautiful though
what are you talking about
i know we have this whole i can't even
believe that you would say that it's not
beautiful in there it was absolutely
gorgeous it was a lot to take in
but you're you're like you're like a 13
year old boy you're like this is boring
it looks like dogs it looked like an
italian's living room you know that
hacky joke that they do where they talk
about that room that's all covered in
plastic that no one can go into
yeah that's what it looks like it's just
ornate i'm going to use the word on my
name but don't you so [ __ ] over it
was so gaudy
every
look you know how you love how the
parisians dress where it's basically all
dark color all dark color and then like
the splash of color with the scarf or
the shoes or the hat and everything else
is sort of was it was it muted
neutral whatever the [ __ ] word is
um
that was the exact opposite
yeah that was the epitome of oh
but look how good this is
i know but there's so much time and
skill that you know goes into
putting all those frescoes up it was
absolutely incredible though you gotta
appreciate that part of it you gotta
appreciate the artistry that goes into
something like the same way i can
appreciate an older movie but also
realize that the dialogue is a little
dated like the the way they decorated it
is a little dated oh i got to get what
is that what do you mean dated i mean
it's it's rome it's one of like the
oldest cities i loved rome i loved rome
i loved everything about it other than
that [ __ ] the only [ __ ] museum i
went to was a stupid
sistine chapel and it sucked
when you go there make a right and go go
right to the ceiling painting yeah and
then get the [ __ ] out of here don't go
to the left and see every chalice they
ever [ __ ] drank out of for like the
next and it wasn't even crowded that day
god forbid if it was [ __ ] crowded
you're gonna you're gonna i swear to god
you're gonna think about abandoning your
family
for good if you're if you're wired like
me
um so by the way um
i i would now say
haven't been here
that uh
paris as far as europe goes yes paris is
like new york city i'd say london
is like a smart chicago
i love saying that just to piss off
people in chicago
and then rome is sort of like a boston
philly kind of thing you know what i
really feel like it's a complete
like travesty that you would try to
compare these amazing european cities to
cities in the united states oh give me a
few no no no this is the city new york
chicago and boston awesome i'm up but
like to try to compare them to like
europe like that's stupid well most of
my listeners
listen most of my listeners are from the
united states of america they need they
need a frame of reference no they don't
you don't need to give them some sort of
like watered-down frame of reference
like no paris is like
london in rome is like rome ah jesus
yeah you're gonna do that person who
comes over here and now [ __ ] just
says that everything over here is is
like it's is paved with gold no i'm not
saying did you see all those fish and
chip eaten jackasses in england i mean
you can't tell me that that's not
chicago
like the amount of heart attacks i got
once and i had an awesome time so i
honestly i don't know that much about i
love chicago i love chicago and i gave
london props where i said that it's like
a smarter chicago
plus while insulting chicago that's what
i gotta do somebody has to go down in
the scenario sorry chicago i'll [ __ ] you
i love chicago and you know me i'm a
[ __ ]
that's all i've been doing is talking
about how dumb i am on this i can't even
go to a [ __ ] museum and enjoy myself
um
oh so also out here um
oh you know what you missed yesterday
you missed these two uh i was gonna say
french people like like what else are
they out there these two french guys
oh that's another thing too uh
um
just like in in what i love about
traveling just about just like in philly
our cheesesteak is just called the
cheesesteak they don't go can i get a
philly cheesesteak they're in philly
just like over here
french toast is not french toast
yeah the pom po
that's what it is there's no french in
it they are french they don't need to
say it
so that's my travel and it's delicious
it's wasn't it really good with that
custard although in boston it's still a
boston cream pie
that's because it's boston yeah we're
morocco
is that where we uh
um oh yeah i would have a [ __ ]
framingham
whatever over there they'd identify
everything in boston just to say that
it's boston related oh shut up it's not
like i'm from boston i love my city but
come on boston is if you want to talk
about dumb
let's talk about boston uh what are you
talking about habit no god
we have harvard boston university i went
to college in boston mit
it's a wonderful uh
mecca of universe mecca of university of
people who come from other places
to continue their education in a very uh
beautiful brisk fall setting otherwise i
would i would it's a bunch of i would
say
jackasses as you say
i would be i would be offended by that
if uh i didn't fit into that [ __ ]
stereotype believe it or not people i
did not get accepted to harvard i got
accepted to wentworth
where's that wentworth was a
construction uh
school
what
this is like this is like [ __ ]
breakfast club when i'm dumb because i
know how to make a lamp
no you're that no you're a genius
because you know how to make a left
that's what you're supposed to say um i
mean and i had no construction skills
whatsoever the reason why i picked it
was because
it just looked like it was a fun job
because i was working in warehousing and
i noticed when you worked with a bunch
of other guys and the boss was sort of
there but not really there you could
just stand around breaking balls all day
so that's why i picked the school right
okay i get accepted there and then i
also got
semi accepted
to northeastern like all right we'll let
you take we'll let you take a couple of
classes mostly how you do you see how
you do and yeah it was a [ __ ]
nightmare i didn't get accepted and then
i went to i went to neither place i went
to i got i got rejected from harvard of
course because i wasn't smart enough my
dad went to harvard so i felt like well
let me apply to harvard i feel like i
should have your family pushed harder to
get into harvard but i didn't and i went
to emerson and it was awesome so and
there's my college story and that's my
college story yeah that's great we're
coming up on an hour here uh what are
you what are you talking about here
i talked about i talked about everything
oh you know something else i've been
trying like every freaking
cigar
uh that you can try out here because
their selection is incredible
um but this is what i have learned
even in paris if you want to buy a cigar
go to a cigar store what's the one that
i went to down the street
ruth's saying honorary i don't know but
yeah you got to go to a specialty place
just like with the uh the boulangerie
you go to the boulangerie that's bakery
yeah to get the croissant and the
baguettes
and i guess you go to a patisserie
to get the like
little cakes and the macaroons and
things like that yeah because other than
that what you're just gonna get ripped
off like it's weird because i they got
all these places it's just it was a
t-a-b-a-c tobacco
yeah you just see those signs you're
like oh there's cuban cigars in there
and you walk in there but they don't
know what the [ __ ] they're doing like i
walked in
to one yesterday and i i bought two
different size like cohibas these
smaller ones and real thin ones
and uh
you're supposed to like basically what
you do is you squeeze the end of it
you're supposed to go in about fifty
percent and then supposed to come back
out i like watching you squeeze your
imaginary yeah
the rest of the cigar regardless of how
hard it is it doesn't make a difference
it's that right there that'll give you a
good draw but the whole thing was was
squishy and i noticed that they seemed
almost a little wet they had the [ __ ]
humidifier up too high and i'm sitting
there smoking it last night it was like
you know it's like i'm smoking wet
leaves it just and it was a cube and it
was i had to finish the thing
how funny was it when i stuck the q-tip
in the end of it to the side
so i get down there
um it was still you know better than any
cigar that i usually get in the uk
that's like when you're like in college
or whatever and you're trying to smoke
like the very the smallest part of the
joint you use a pair of tweezers to
smoke out of it that was it yeah exactly
there's a famous story because i've only
heard it once in my life i'm not going
to say it's famous
uh castro when he was at the u.n he
actually lit up
during the whole meeting
of the minds of people around the world
and as he's sitting there listening he's
smoking a cuban which i think is a big
[ __ ] you to the us
like yeah you guys wish you could be
smoking these and in the end
he what he used as a roach clip was some
part of his glasses
he stuck it in there and he was holding
his glasses like hitting it like a roach
really yeah
dressed like he was on mash
[Laughter]
um i got you a croissant from the
boulangerie
okay what flavor
plain the butter one how do you say it
[Music]
um
okay let's read a couple of these things
here uh
fake sports enthusiasm
um
dear billy balls between the final four
and the super bowl which one do you
think attracts the most fake female
sports fans all just running out the
door in whatever color they're rooting
for never watched any regular season
games which is it i say the final four
uh first of all i don't think that you
gotta just say that it's women uh yeah
[ __ ] you
oh jesus
i'm not saying that because nia is here
either although i might subconsciously
because we have to spend the day
the most fake female sports fans there's
only fake female sports friends i would
say
oh i would well the super bowl is brutal
for the fake female sports fan it's
[ __ ] brutal it's brutal for everybody
because everyone most people pretend
like they give a [ __ ] about the super
bowl when they don't they just want to
watch the goddamn commercials
that's a very that's a very ignorant
point of view what you're doing right
now is because you're looking out your
own head and saying this is the view of
the world
it's important thing isn't it you're
part of a lot of people are i don't know
you're part of the problem you're the
woman who shows up that doesn't give a
[ __ ] and talks
i don't show up you know i don't go to
games or any of that kind of [ __ ] with
you because i usually don't care no no
i'm so but the super bowl you do show up
you go to a super bowl party yeah you
eat the food you talk during the game
and you shut up during the commercial
and then when the game comes back on you
go oh my god how would you think that
one cost that one wasn't that good that
is not what i do at all you are lying
right now i don't ever do that i'm never
more embarrassed
there's so many super bowl parties with
you and i've never done that i usually
dip out
during the game or i'm sort of sitting
there watching it and not really paying
attention
you're over in the corner giggling with
your friends during the game all i hear
is ha ha now
[Laughter]
i would actually say the super bowl
because the super bowl has become like a
national holiday and it's the fact that
it is
one day it is on the weekend it's only
just for one [ __ ] day
and uh
the fact that there's gonna be food and
all of that stuff for non-sports fans to
still enjoy
um and then all the other extra [ __ ]
hyping like oh we need to turn the
channel and watch the puppy bowl or
whatever the [ __ ] it is or oh my yeah oh
my god [ __ ] like the puppy ball
that's cute yeah
[ __ ] bruno mars is gonna be playing
at halftime he killed it he did kill oh
he's awesome he killed it he's awesome
i'm not saying he didn't but i'm just
saying
better than tom petty um
tom petty you know when tom petty came
out looking like the guy in the nickel
oh that yeah yeah the blonde
last dance mary that guy yeah he looked
literally who's the guy in the nickel is
that thomas jefferson or is that uh
of thomas jefferson or uh tom petty
i'm tom petty all right girlfriend
cheating
on her diet
what up billy retinov i already don't
like this person um why you don't like
that delivery
no that's actually pretty funny
girlfriend cheating dot dot on her on a
diet
that sounds like a gay guy wrote that
utter diet
um
i'm 27 years old and have a girlfriend
of six years whom i live with when we
first got together she had a sexy
athletic body that all changed last year
when she got promoted and started
working long hours in a high stress
position uh she began smoking weed
almost every night claiming it helped
her relax after a hard day's work yeah
man she also started eating like [ __ ]
lost of lots of fast food larger
portions etc she's probably 60 to 70
pounds heavier than when we first met
and on her 5-3 frame it [ __ ] shows
man after ignoring myself that would
show on a six foot frame after my after
ignoring my probably 60 to 70 pounds
heavier
after ignoring my subtle hints for the
last year i finally sat her down last
month and said enough is enough she
needs to make an effort to get healthier
i did everything to support her in
losing weight i paid for an expensive
supplement program that her co-workers
recommended i started making her healthy
lunches every day to take to work when
she'd get home from work i'd have a
healthy dinner ready for on the table i
even paid for a new gym membership and
bought her a new bicycle today i found a
hidden cachet of fast food wrappers in
the garage
this led me to believe to look at her
bank statements from the last month
she's been picking up fast food on her
way home from work nearly every day
since we talked it sounds like a biggest
loser story not only that she'd also buy
fast food at lunches sometimes too
suggesting that she was tossing the
lunches i made her in the trash this
really pissed me off i'm a guy who takes
care of my body and want a woman who
does the same she's only 24 and hasn't
had children she shouldn't have a beer
gut jowls and saggy tits
you were so in the pocket you were so in
the pocket [ __ ] take your computer
and throw it out the goddamn window
can you please finish the rest of this
so i can go off on this [ __ ]
please just finish it because i swear to
[ __ ] god i swear to god i think he's
making a lot of good points he oh my god
the fact that i said oh my god wait a
minute wait a minute don't don't scream
too [ __ ] too close to the computer i
don't i can't i can't use a mixer this
week the fact that i spent all this
money and effort on her only to have her
sabotage it and hide it from me makes me
seriously call our relationship into
question
what would you do in my situation oh my
god mia's taking off her shoes god you
know what you know what
hey we have to be quiet i know i know i
know you know what you shallow
just
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] guy who wrote
this letter let me explain something to
you right now you think you care about
her health you don't care about her
health you certainly don't care about
her state of mind all you care about is
whether or not your girlfriend's hot
enough what for for you for your friends
for society you don't give a [ __ ] you
said yourself she's got this job she's
stressed out and so she's stress eating
that's what a lot of people do okay and
you're sitting here you seem like you
were well intentioned right but now it
seems like you're just being [ __ ]
shallow because you don't care you don't
care about anything that's going on
inside of her physically or or mentally
or emotionally all you care about is
what she looks like and now you're mad
because she's like hiding it from you
and you're calling in the question of
relationship you've been with her for
six years and you're gonna call into a
question her relationship how she feels
about you because she's going through
something emotional why don't you talk
to her about how she feels instead of
trying to put a band-aid on the problem
and making it seem like you care when
you obviously don't give a [ __ ] okay
you're a shallow superficial douchebag
and she should dump your ass and get hot
even hotter than when she's 24 minutes
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute time out climb up
climb up now how would she go about
getting even hotter
by losing 60 to 70 pounds no you know
what she could get hotter by finding a
guy who's making more money and who's
nicer and like just a better so she
should become a gold digging fat [ __ ]
no no wait a minute wait a minute now
listen listen
here's the deal forget her even time out
you're being too hot i'm going to tell
you right now
no no no no no no no
you're being mean she had a better body
when she was a teenager than my mom she
was when she started to get into like
her mouth what a surprise time out
unbelievable time out what happens oh my
god when people get older and have like
grown up responsibilities
that's that's really crazy how that
happens sir you you you hit you hit the
and you've got what like a six pack and
a full head of hair and you're just like
the hottest guy ever right and that's
not going to change for you maybe in 10
years if you go through something and
you're having a hard time and the person
that you supposedly love and cares about
you and has been with you for six years
just decides to what toss you aside
because you gained some weight [ __ ] you
wait a minute okay time out okay can i
defend this guy
a little bit more sure that's what you
do you defend the [ __ ] who write
into you so go ahead
well yeah i can't bite the hand of the
feet
no i'm i'm not defending this guy just
to defend this guy okay first of all
you're ignoring the fact
that
this
guy he sat down with her
in a nice way
okay in a caring way yeah to be five
foot three and put on 60 to 70 pounds
you're setting yourself up for heart
disease and you're gonna die and this
guy she hasn't even had kids yet
okay time out time out and she has to go
through all of that which you know mia
okay you like that's
that's already hard enough is it she's
only 24 years old you should not be 60
to 70 pounds yeah 30 pounds overweight
is obese this girl is is two times
on her way to three times at 24 she's
blowing out her body and she's she's
never going to be in shape again and
she's going to live a miserable [ __ ]
life because a very difficult life
because of it she's going to blow out
our knees i'm telling you all of this
[ __ ] is going to come and this guy he
did not sit down and say hey you used to
be hot and now you're not he said
time out time out
he sat down with her like an adult and
said that basically i'm concerned about
you
um
you know we said i love you i'm
concerned about you i want to help you
get healthier this guy is making lunches
for he's paying for a gym he's doing all
of this stuff and in the end
when he's trying to help her out and
then she's going behind his her
his back
eating which she's doing it out of a
shame thing he felt betrayed and then
the anger comes out and then that's when
he says beer gut jowls and saggy tits
okay now this is the thing there like
it's unnecessary for him to like put it
like i understand what you're saying
well he has to because he can't say that
to her and he can't get he has to get
his anger out or he has to make a
[ __ ] joke he has to do something and
here this guy is also 27 years old he
says he keeps himself in [ __ ] shape
which you know something that's not fair
to your partner it's not fair to your
partner to go out and put on that kind
of weight okay if she's 24 years old
though she can't bounce back it's not
like she's 44 she's 24. okay like i know
it's hard to lose that kind of weight of
course but she can do it but i'm just
saying like i'm not getting
he's doing all this stuff where you like
do all like the physical stuff but he
seems like he's incapable of being like
emotionally supported
what are you talking about he was he was
in the beginning he was in the beginning
he did this what he's doing in the end
is he's talking to me guided guy
she's 24 years old hasn't he had kids
she shouldn't have a beer gut jowls and
saggy tits you know he's coming out like
a football coach
well she doesn't need a football coach
she didn't say it to her she didn't say
it to her he said it to me
suggesting she was tossing the lunches i
made her in the trash yeah who knows if
she might have she might have just
probably eaten them both she's probably
eating them both right
what would you do with my situation that
helped this [ __ ] guy out he seems
like he's keeping himself in shape he's
be he's actually a great boyfriend if he
was a dick
he would have said i'm breaking up with
you because you have a beer gut and
jowls he didn't he tried to help her
with the [ __ ] problem
guys problem solved okay help this guy
connect with her emotionally
so i mean look she's got this high
stress [ __ ] job but like
at some point
you know you gotta settle into the
stress of your job or you have to get a
new [ __ ] job but this is what it's
doing to you
all right
and yeah i got to tell you you get 60 to
70 pounds overweight at 24 [ __ ] years
of age what's going to happen at 34. and
yeah that is a legitimate question it's
a legitimate question because
that weight thing
is
you know it starts happening
people died nia
not to bring up a bad [ __ ] stuff yeah
you're really like you're kind of like
taking it to the extreme though i mean
but nia if you're gonna think about
being with somebody for the rest of
their life you're gonna have kids with
this person they're already this much
overweight they're not gonna be be there
they're not gonna [ __ ] be there
all right
fine maybe i went too far when i was
calling him an [ __ ] and all that kind
of stuff man i think he went a normal
reaction
yeah
it's that last it's that last thing you
know what i mean because you know what
you're right everything that he says
he's doing in terms of making her
healthy meals and buying her bike and
the gym membership that's all well and
good and maybe that's this is the part
about men and women that's difficult
because yes you guys try to problem
solve you don't
try to connect on an emotional level and
say like you bury the emotions right and
you go to the gym
exactly where like
it sounds like what she needs she needs
to blow off steam and a lot of people do
they they eat they drink they smoke weed
they do other drugs this is how they
cope these are how people cope that's
another thing she starts using [ __ ]
uh um
i can't i mean alcohol is a drug but now
she's no weed and that increases your
hunger for most people like like you
wouldn't believe so yeah and you don't
want a salad when you're high you want
pizza and cheeseburger and nachos let me
ask you this let me ask you this let's
just say
you're dating me
all right
you know we've been going out for two
years
i'm in great shape
and then all of a sudden the stress of
the road
i put on 60 to 70 pounds and start
smoking weed now you're going to tell me
that you're not going to entertain
breaking up with me
you're not going to sit there and be
like this is going to be the father of
my kids this is the person i'm going to
spend my life with this guy he was
acting like he's in [ __ ] wayne's
world
and uh uncle buck all at the same time
you know what i honestly can't say that
i would if you all of a sudden that's
all you were doing with yourself and
whenever you weren't on the road you
were just sitting around smoking weed
and you know what you're being [ __ ]
if i came home imagine my pasty freckled
torso
with man tits
right my [ __ ]
navel the size of a half dollar now yeah
smoking weed
and just sitting there [ __ ] you know
that's going to affect my sex drive and
now i'm getting on top of you
sweating all right yeah you got to get
on top of me i look like i'm pregnant i
mean give me a [ __ ] break
right and then you're walking down the
street and you're seeing all these other
guys going to the gym
and you're in the prime of your [ __ ]
life yeah and you're going to pick a
mate for the rest of your [ __ ] life
and i'm already looking like i've worked
on wall street for 30 [ __ ] years
you're not going to sit there and have
any second thoughts come on you
i mean i might not be as sexually
attracted to you that's for sure
but i wouldn't
tear the band-aid off and just say what
you're going to say but i wouldn't be
like i need to i would that's the other
how would you approach me how would you
know but listen
this is the problem that i have
especially with this whole letter the
fact that i spent all this money and
effort on her only to have her sabotage
and hide it for me makes me seriously
call our relationship into question why
does that call
your relationship into questions she's
being deceptive
yeah because she's going through some
emotional [ __ ] but she's being deceptive
about food it's not like she's like
cheating on she's like you know what i
know she is foreign
you know oh or do you really not love me
now because you know you're not
following this diet that we agreed that
you would fall like that's not that's
not a fair comparison to make on
somebody like that's not it's really not
fair to do that no it's is it fair to do
what she's doing
well it's she's not doing it against
like against him
and as as a way to hurt him i know she
so you can't so you can't say is it fair
for her to be doing that to him you know
something this is this is not what's
happening but this is this classic
[ __ ] female thing where you guys are
right when you're right and you're right
when you're wrong like you're acting
like
you think she's doing this to hurt him
well why can't she be a little more
mature and just be just say like listen
why can't she sit down with him
and just level with him and let him know
just say listen i gotta be honest with
you
i know that you care about me i know
that you sat down and you had this this
conversation with me and i know that i
certainly do this and this and this but
i'm actually doing that and i'm actually
you know not going to the gym
and i feel bad that you're wasting your
money and all that and you're taking all
this time to make a lunch every morning
how loving is that that he's doing she's
sure she should do that yeah all right
then she's not 100
free of guilt the thing about it is nia
is that guys are guys and we talk like
guys and guys
just get to the [ __ ] heart of the
matter
i don't like the fact when he said he
looked at her bank statements
from last month she's been picking up
fast food on her way home for like
nearly every day i gotta tell you yeah
that's a chick thing to do go through
somebody's email and snoop he's sneaking
it is
and i don't i don't think it's smart to
do i think it's ridiculous and also it's
like don't look because you more than
likely going to see something that you
don't want well i'll be checking your
emails later on today
i have nothing to hide all right
all my youtube all right so what what
should he do in his situation
well first of all i should probably
apologize for saying [ __ ] you and
calling you an [ __ ]
um
but yeah you should just have sit down
and have a talk with her and just say
i'm concerned about you and what's
what's going on with you emotionally
like tell me what's going on how does he
deal with
maybe we can like go for a walk after
work and you can tell me about your day
when he brings up
when he brings up the fact that he
snooped and looked at her he does not
need to do that well let's just let's
just say he does because at this point
now his girlfriend she's gonna freak out
and she can get a lot of weight behind
those punches now
you're such a dick
um
no you should just say i'm i'm i'm i'm
worried about you because i feel like
you're you're going through some stuff
and i tried to help you but maybe it's
not enough do you want to talk to me do
you want to talk to somebody else how do
you how are you feeling because she
probably
feels about herself she probably feels
terrible about what her she does she's
gaining that much weight none of her
clothes fit anymore she knows how she
looks
she probably feels absolutely terrible
and her one solace
is that she's got this boyfriend who's
home and he cares about her and he loves
her and she's abuser
that's not you don't throw that word
around
she's a big long word
she don't do [ __ ] she's taking it
amazing she's taking advantage stop it
she's taking advantage of that love
she's not you're making it like that's
why i don't like that's what you're
saying
she's not trying to hurt him by doing
this she's hurting her
you don't know her and you don't know
him
exactly so why are you right and i'm
wrong i'm not i'm not saying i'm right
i'm giving you my opinion isn't that why
i'm here
you really have a beautiful profile you
know that
um don't try to throw me on absolutely i
appreciate that but don't try to throw
me off all right that was a legitimate
thought but i was trying to throw you a
little bit
no listen if um
i understand what the [ __ ] i was going
to say
it would be very hard for what we were
just talking about
no no she probably feels bad for herself
yeah here's something what if she
doesn't
what if she doesn't give a [ __ ] there
are those people how do you know there
aren't those people who just don't give
a [ __ ] because she's a woman and she's
5'3 and she's put on more than like 10
pounds which is it's just devastating
for us i'm 5'4 and i've been what about
25 pounds heavier i understand still
look good though
you lazed me when i was a little bit
heavier yeah i was still alive you said
you liked it when i was a little bit
thicker so listen i understand it does
show it it shows like nobody's business
you are right sir it shows
um
[Music]
to have your formerly tight
hot body girlfriend all of a sudden not
be that way i know and if she looks if
she looks like she's a retired athlete
in her 50s at 24 i mean what is he
supposed to do he is 27.
so what so he is still at that shallow
age where he's like you know calling
into question his relationship based on
your partner's weight gain no that's
that's the level of maturity that he's
uh yeah that's the yeah listen
that's a very serious [ __ ] thing
to be that that overweight at that age i
mean
if you do that to your body and you stay
that way for 20 years
i mean it's
your body can only take that for so long
and when you're thinking about starting
a family with somebody they have to be
around they got to be involved
they can't be over in the corner
you know with no energy lethargic and
and and then having on top of that all
kinds of [ __ ] hell that's another
thing tunia you're not going to be able
to get [ __ ] health insurance
i mean what she's doing is really is
effective both and i'm not trying to be
a dick here but like they're not even
engaged though this is just his
girlfriend that's how you get to lose
weight you should propose
she'll lose weight with the quickness
trust me i know yeah but then once they
get married she's gonna go right back to
the doritos
uh well then that does that just means
that there is a
a significant emotional thing that needs
to be addressed so
all that stuff that you did while you
got our um this great bike and a gym
membership and all that stuff to support
first of all that should that should
tell you that a person is only going to
change their lifestyle if they want to
number one that's the first lesson
that's with drugs or food or anything
number two
that that means you need to go deeper
than just the kind of like these are the
things
i got the answer right you're either
talking or you're suggesting therapy or
you go to therapy to talk to talk about
it or something she probably needs to
that she's got like some sort of like
eating i have the answer food addiction
or something i got the answer she's
probably just [ __ ] depressed and when
you're depressed you smoke weed and you
gain weight like she's depressed he
needs stressed out he needs
to sit down
and decide
if it's worth it
if this is does he love this person
enough
to ride through this [ __ ] storm
if
if
if you're not if you don't feel that way
then you should just walk
okay and then
breaking our heart
is better than marrying her when you
don't love her so just break her heart
the stress of that the sadness of that
she won't be able to eat that big king
every day and she'll probably drop like
15. is he is he stopped loving her
because if that's the case
then
he's calling their relationship into
question so i don't know
i don't know i don't know
why because he's being honest why can't
you [ __ ] be honest why can't guys be
these d
who we are we we are visually you know
what i love about women is you you
[ __ ] want to use that [ __ ] where
visually attractive get you a [ __ ]
drink
or get you get you out of some [ __ ] what
do you mean
like that doesn't [ __ ] work you want
to use it when it works for you and then
you you want it you want to use that
weakness when it's to your [ __ ]
advantage and then when it's the other
way you want us to be these [ __ ]
understanding goddamn people
you want us to be guys when it gets you
a free [ __ ] drink we want so we want
guys to love us whether we're like the
hot body or we gain some weight that's
what we want we want to not yeah you
want your cake no literally no we want
we want to not be we want to live in a
world where we don't have to even
[ __ ] have this conversation that's
what exactly yeah i want to be rude and
fat and and and sheltered
actually do whatever i want to do and i
want you to steal food and fat and
disgusting and ridiculous and you get to
do that but women can't do that actually
we have to be like the hot body
otherwise you call our relationship into
question
oh so this one guy is everybody now
he's not everybody but we're just we're
talking about just a general you know
what
you're so you just you just said women
like to do this and women like to do
that like it's all women that's what i
do that's what i do yeah but i'm a [ __ ]
you're supposed to be a higher being
you're a female we are higher beings
you're not trust us you're not we are
just as dumb as we are just in different
areas you know you don't think so no
being being an emotional person makes
you tuned into things that you
as a male with your basic [ __ ]
basicness
can't understand so we already are high
and we can like carry children we've got
some spiritual level [ __ ] that you'll
never understand exactly and you know we
also have we have some plow through some
[ __ ] that you don't understand
that you don't understand don't you
think you're cloudy
finish a [ __ ] thought no can't you
have can you be a plow through [ __ ] and
an emotional you need both of those
things don't you think yeah it's called
the ying and the yank but for some
reason you think yeah yang is better
than my yin
and that's the [ __ ] problem and
there's 50 000 shows on [ __ ] tv as
much as you ladies complain about the
images on tv there's a zillion [ __ ]
things on tv that are telling you that
you guys are right and guys are morons
start with 90 of the [ __ ] advertising
when they show a man and a [ __ ] woman
in a relationship like that ridiculous
one from a few years ago that i'll never
[ __ ]
believe that they were actually where
she's sitting at the computer and the
guys outside finds a beehive and
literally sticks a broom handle up into
the [ __ ] thing
and is getting stung by bees because
he's a dumb guy and she has to sit down
and handle the family business at the
[ __ ] computer
okay please do the female the
chauvinistic version of that [ __ ]
commercial
what do you mean do they shove in a sick
version of that one
have the guy figuring out the family
business on a [ __ ] computer is she
sitting there looking through a fashion
magazine or
that's not even at the same level of
ridiculousness what is the female
version of sticking a broom handle into
a [ __ ] beehive they're assuming that
the woman is is taking care of like the
day-to-day run the household stuff that
the man is trying to be working no he
doesn't know so with the metaphor so
they're trying to appeal to a woman's
sensibility so that she'll like the
product and then she'll buy that what
about
what about the metaphor that's going on
there that he's such a [ __ ] he's trying
to stick his [ __ ] pole into any
goddamn hole he can find
that's not knowing not knowing he can
get stung at any moment yeah i want him
getting herpes
uh dear billy bounce what music are you
listening to these days what's on your
ipod what's the lovely neo listening to
what do you listen to when you work out
that chiseled lee marvin body
uh it's as old as lee marvin's party
um
what am i listening to these days i
don't [ __ ] know
what i'm i usually listen to [ __ ] that
makes me want to play drums
uh or learns
some drum [ __ ] so i i have no idea
what's last night when we actually
watched
we were watching comedy central because
we were we were uh their website we were
jet lagged yeah
and when i watched key and peel
and i watch the workaholics
and uh
broad city
when i watched all that did was make me
feel [ __ ] old
it made me feel [ __ ] old like uh
i mean all right let me go back a second
they're all [ __ ] hilarious
like i was legitimately left laughing
through all of that right yeah okay
but i didn't get
i didn't get so much of this [ __ ]
now i didn't get it like what was that
thing
that hannibal burst thing that he said i
didn't even get it oh yeah he was
talking about childish gambino donald
glover
it was his interview with nerve.com that
hannibal burris did it was like we asked
and hannibal burrs for sex advice
and in the end they were asking him if
he would want to do like a mixtape and a
few raps and now he's like yeah i
thought about it but i'm not gonna you
know go full like childish gambino and
this and then the other and then he made
a reference to like you know oh we
figured out like childish gambino is
really like bill burr and that's that's
that or like when he does stand up
and you just could not understand that
no matter
is also a childish gambino you just
didn't you didn't seem to and the whole
time i heard donald glover all i was
picturing was danny brooks
no and then it's donald glover yeah oh
my god and then the cruel show jesus
christ oh my god everything on the cruel
show is
hilarious i mean go on what am i
listening to since they were asking what
was the lovely nia listening to um i
actually downloaded sam smith's album
um based on his performance when louis
ck did snl actually it was
another recent appearance that louis did
it wasn't the first time around um so
sam smith is awesome just has a
beautiful voice i've actually been
making a lot of mixes of like old stuff
a lot of old hip-hop i've been listening
to a lot like 90s
what makes hip-hop hop um but i love i
love um what's the like the latest
like maybe um pusha t's album
is like it's something that i listen to
phenomenal
i have no idea what i i i played i
played it for you
you liked a couple of his his verses but
overall i don't think you were into it
because you're not really into
hip like rap music right now
right would you say
i you know i i
i can't get i can't listen to if you're
gonna [ __ ] walk around your house or
your apartment
talking about all the stuff that you
have in there
it's just boring as [ __ ] to me
um i like storytellers i will never like
those those guys that tell stories
you know
about guns and selling drugs if it's
actually real
it sounds real like they actually did
that's why i love jay-z and biggie
because they actually did that [ __ ] and
then they talked about it and it was
like nas is like that it was like
listening to a movie yeah nasa's like
that i like that stuff um
you know
but you don't like i don't like west i
don't i like
kanye west is so far up his own ass
it's just like that is true yeah i've
never heard like who walks around
calling himself a genius
who does that i mean there's like
right there you're not a genius
you're an idiot
like i don't and i don't understand what
i hate when he also stretches out the
words
it's like what are you trying to dumb it
down for me you either don't have enough
material for this [ __ ] song to finish
it oh it's a style it's like uh you know
what are you doing
[Music]
that one that i listen to because i like
oh my god talk about being apropos
it's i believe it's called n words in
paris
um n words in paris
uh yeah there's a part in the middle
where he stretches out the
like jay-z kills it and then he comes on
and he starts jake and we get married at
the mall oh
and it just keeps going and going and
going like and i just feel like show me
why you deserve to have it all yeah and
it stinks it's not clever and he's
slowing it down like i'm supposed to be
on the other end like oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
well whatever i'm i'm sure a zillion
kanye oh insane can't be wrong
he's a genius saint vincent
is another one
that i'm listening to
i guess the most contemporary thing i've
listened to in the past couple years is
probably mute math and that's only
because andrew who does the podcast told
me to check them out and say drum is
[ __ ] awesome andrew them list has
wonderful taste in music can we just say
that on podcasts
all right we got to wrap this up because
we got to go look at that arrogant broad
down in the building
um
oh before i end i got to uh just
unbelievable sad day in comedy yesterday
the great john panette
uh
that's the way and i gotta tell you i
gotta tell you a great job in that story
he was just
an unbelievable guy i only i only got to
meet him a handful of times but he's one
of those guys you met him the first time
it's like you know you know like cliche
like you knew him forever first time i
ever saw him i had all he heard was the
legend of john finnett where basically
he started doing comedy and like within
six months was headlining
because he had he didn't have the
material yet because he'd only been
doing six months but his charisma and
how hard he was killing he was just such
a natural
that
we're in boston where it was just such
it was like headlining was so solidified
like you you like we always said by the
time we came around you had to leave
boston to headline boston because the
the boston comedy gods weren't leaving
and you weren't going to get funnier
than them so you had to go out and get
tv credits
to just do a headlining set at the
[ __ ] comedy vault
uh but john panette was so funny he
plowed through all of that
in six months so the first time i see
the guy after hearing the legend of the
guy i'm at knicks comedy stop uh
on kevin knox's show
and this is after the stand-up boom
ended the 80s ended in the early 90s
when i started out so and they didn't
learn how to promote a club because they
never had to because people just went to
comedy clubs so now for the first time
ever they had to learn how to promote it
they would still learn it's long story
short it was a tuesday night at nix
there was maybe 28 people in the crowd
and john panette comes in
and just says hey can i get up and do
some time and they put him on and i
watched him and he did
12 minutes
and he made those 28 people
it sounded like a [ __ ] jet was
landing he had them dying laughing and
he got a standing ovation
like he had done like a 90 minute
blistering set just doing 12 minutes
just ah it was one of those things i had
never seen anybody get a standing
ovation but i knew at the end they were
gonna stand up and i remember he just he
just went on he just kind of like sit
down sit down i just remember going like
what the [ __ ] was that
and um
fortunately i never had to try to follow
him
i did one show with him um
i can't remember where the hell we were
it was me him kathleen madigan was just
a [ __ ] great
lineup of people and like he closed it
and jesus christ
he was one of those guys that he would
and that's that boston style it's like i
got you and i'm not letting you go
and i'm not letting you get up and like
nobody
was the epitome of that more than them
so gonna miss you buddy
and that's it that's the podcast for
this week